[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROGER MARTINEZ: Welcome
to the Quickstart tutorial
for Cloud Endpoints.
Let's get started using
Cloud Endpoints by activating
the Cloud Shell in our console.
We'll download the project
code to our instance.
If we take a look at
the scripts directory,
we'll see that we've got a
couple of scripts in there.
Let's start by
running deploy_api.sh.
This script will deploy an API
included in the project files
to Cloud Endpoints.
Next, let's deploy
the API backend,
by executing deploy_app.sh.
This will create an App
Engine flexible environment
to host the API Backend
and deploy our sample
API to App Engine.
To see our API in action,
we'll run query_api.sh.
This command takes
one argument--
a three-letter airport code.
For example, if we
enter EWR, our API
returns Newark Liberty
International Airport.
Cool.
We've just deployed and
tested an API in Endpoints.
Once we have an API
deployed, we can also
track API activity
and gain insight
into our users and usage
with Stackdriver logging.
In order to do
that, first, let's
enable the Service Control
API on our project.
Now, let's generate some
activity to work with.
The generate_traffic.sh
script will generate requests
to our API for five minutes.
That will give us plenty of
data to check out metrics for.
Once traffic has
been generated, we
can check out the
Endpoints Services page.
Right off the bat,
we've got visibility
into the number of
requests per second,
500 errors, and latency.
We can check out the logs
for the methods of our API
through this link at
the bottom of the page.
We just deployed our API
and started generating data,
so there aren't that
many errors to be seen.
But as you can see,
every request to our API
is logged with
details, like timestamp
of the request, the method
called, and the HTTP response
code.
And that's it.
That's how easy it is to get
set up with Cloud Endpoints
to deploy your very own API.
[MUSIC PLAYING]